Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where entrepreneurs
seek an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
Sharks,
meet the Spooner.
Who's ready
for a little sugar?
Narrator: If the Sharks
hear a great idea...
That's the American dream!
Narrator: ...they'll invest
their own money...
You need a strategic partner.
What you need is capital.
Narrator: ...and fight
each other for a deal.
I'm gonna put an offer
on the table,
but you have to get
the other half.
I'm interested
in partnering with her, but --
Except for him.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must get the full amount
they're asking for, or they'll
walk away with nothing.
I mean, people are
addicted to this stuff.
This isn't the best
that you're gonna do.
Lieu: My family escaped
the Vietnam War.
I'm gonna create success
no matter what.
You bring a shareholder.
That's a whole different
ballgame.
No, not with
the right shareholder.
You sh-- I don't need
your opinion, Barbara.
Kevin, can you leave?
You're making the children cry.
Narrator:
Who are the Sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's premier
$2 billion real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, son of
an immigrant factory worker,
founded one of
the world's preeminent
cyber-security firms.
Lori Greiner, the Queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
more than 400 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in sales.
And Mark Cuban,
esteemed billionaire tech mogul
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas mavericks.
First into the Tank
is a healthier version
of a favorite treat.
Hello.
My name is Heather Saffer.
I'm from Rochester, New York.
I'm seeking $75,000
for 20% equity
in my company,
Dollop Gourmet,
the first healthier
and tastier answer
to one of the scariest
processed foods
on the planet -- frosting.
Who doesn't love frosting?
It's so sinfully decadent.
But the problem with
store-bought shelves'
table frostings
is that they're horrible
for you,
laden with chemicals,
artificial food dyes,
some even contain animal lard.
Who wants to put that
on their cake?
Dollop Gourmet frosting
is better for you
and tastes incredible.
Dollop is non-GMO, gluten free,
vegan, and 100% all natural.
It even contains
half as much sugar.
Sharks, I need your help.
Who's ready
for a little sugar?
[ Chuckles ]
-Yeah?
-Bring it.
-I have some samples for you.
-I'm a frosting freak.
You get the redless
velvet cupcake.
Ooh. Thank you.
Thank you.
Very nice presentation.
-Thank you.
Saffer: And then, Mark,
you got vanilla.
Cuban: That works.
-Hi, Lori.
-Hi, Robert!
How are things
on the "Shark Tank"?
Saffer: So, the cupcake
is our vanilla frosting.
We use pure
Madagascar bourbon vanilla,
the highest-quality vanilla.
And then, next to that,
you have the peanut butter
cookie dough frosting.
There's the sea salted
caramel frosting.
And then, lastly, you have
the hot chocolate frosting.
Stuff tastes great.
What's in it?
Thank you.
Mmm.
We use organic
sustainable palm oil.
We use organic cane sugar,
and half as much.
What's
the shelf life?
It's a year, unopened.
How are you
selling it now?
We're selling it
in retail stores.
So, I launched the company
less than a year ago
in all 85
Wegmans locations.
A couple months ago --
-That is a great store.
-It is.
We got into all 215 Meijers
stores in the midwest.
Next month, we'll be launching
in two Whole Foods regions...
Wow.
...and in 152 HEB stores.
How did you get into
the frosting business?
So, in 2009, I was working
at a car dealership.
It was probably
my 30th job.
I hadn't finished college.
I decided that
I wanted to start a business,
and I saw that cupcakes
were becoming popular back then.
No kidding.
Who's got the number-one
cupcake?
Right here!
-I know! I know!
And so I decided I would attend
the school of Google and YouTube
and teach myself how to bake,
so I'm a self-taught baker.
I opened a bakery in Rochester
and aligned myself
with the wrong people,
and I lost everything.
Oh.
Um, I had to pay off my debts
and dissolve the company.
It was by a different name.
How much money did you lose
in that first bakery venture?
Probably about $20,000.
-Wow.
-That was my life savings.
Within three weeks,
I said I wasn't gonna stop.
I started a new bakery.
Everyone said I couldn't do it.
Corcoran:
Where did you get the cash?
I borrowed $4,000
from my parents.
That bakery became
really successful.
I won Food Network's
"Cupcake Wars."
I was gonna say
I recognize you.
-Do you really?
-Yes.
What are sales now?
We've done $170,000
since November.
This year, what do you think
you'll do?
About another $50,000.
$200,000 for the year,
you think?
Yeah. Approximately,
a little bit more.
What are your margins
on this product?
The margin's 40%.
I make it in Wisconsin.
I have a co-packer.
I make it for $2.30.
That sounds
a little high.
Which is the most expensive
ingredient in here?
The palm oil's
really expensive.
The jars are also expensive.
What is Wegmans
selling each jar for?
Wegmans sells each jar
for $6.99.
And how does that
compare with
the leading category killer,
and you know which one I mean.
Yes, I do.
What do they
sell theirs for?
They sell about $1.50.
-That's -- wow.
-Really?
-Huge issue.
Saffer: It's a --
It's a lot higher.
Corcoran: Wow.
We're also selling
on Amazon for $12.99.
What?!
Cuban: It sells for $6.99
in the stores,
and $12.99 on Amazon?
Yes, but we haven't
had any complaints.
Herjavec:
Is that a problem?
Nope. We haven't had
any complaints about price.
People are paying for it.
The formula that won
in "Cupcake Wars,"
is it the same formula
that we have here?
It is not.
I actually wrote a cookbook --
"The Dollop Book of Frosting".
Herjavec: And you wrote
a cookbook in your spare time!
I wrote a cookbook,
yep.
I researched
how to write a cookbook
and actually found
an agent,
got a book deal
with a publisher.
Do you have a pilot's license
and a PhD?
I don't!
So, which was the frosting
that won?
So, the frosting's are
in the cookbook that won, so --
Greiner: Okay.
Is it the same formula
that's in these,
or did you change it?
Saffer: Nope. I changed it
'cause they were butter-based,
and I really wanted
to create something
that everyone could enjoy.
So I wanted it to be
gluten-free, vegan,
dairy-free, soy-free.
It's something
that everyone can eat
because it's allergen friendly,
and that's a huge craze
right now.
Herjavec: Heather, let me --
let me tell you where I'm at.
First of all,
very impressive.
You are the definition
of "don't know when to quit."
Thank you.
It's not how many times
you fall down,
it's how many times
you get up.
I don't like frosting.
Cuban: [ Chuckles ]
Like, I --
I just -- I just don't.
Really?
Yeah.
Not so crazy
about the product.
You got to be passionate
about the product, so...
Saffer: Yes.
...love you.
I'm out.
I appreciate it.
You've got four other people
that obviously like frosting.
O'Leary:
Let me get the ball rolling --
I have a huge database
of people that buy cupcakes.
I am the number-one cupcake
FedEx'd in America toady.
Uh-huh.
So I would like
to go to that database,
cut a deal with Wicked,
and make this part of our
product line with your brand.
Okay.
How is your partner
gonna feel about that,
that you're bringing
in a competitor?
I think if -- if --
No, this is icing.
But your cupcakes
have icing.
We don't sell icing.
But -- But they all
have icing on them.
This is to sell
to the supplemental market
who actually bakes,
'cause one of the product lines
you don't know yet
about Wicked
is we're gonna provide
the actual baked goods
so you can
bake yourself.
I can really help you
move it online.
Have the infrastructure
already, have the customers.
Have to work a deal
with my partners at Wicked,
but I think they're
gonna warm up to this idea.
Okay.
I'll give you $75,000
for 33.3%,
'cause I'm gonna have
to give them some
equity to make it work.
No, you're not.
I am.
Corcoran: Kevin, you're
asking her to welcome a partner
she knows nothing about.
Barbara, you can make
all the noise you want.
I want you to understand
the offer,
'cause I don't really care
what she thinks about it.
All right?
Saffer: I got it.
I will give you $75,000
for 33.3%.
Okay. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
I really appreciate
that offer.
I think it's awesome.
And?
Narrator: One Shark is out,
but Heather
has one offer on the table
for her healthy frosting
company, Dollop Gourmet.
I will give you $75,000
for 33.3%.
Okay. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
I really appreciate
that offer.
I think it's awesome.
And?
Herjavec: Barbara?
Yeah, I'd like to make an offer
for Lori and I.
Wow.
I'd like to get 30%,
so there's enough skin
in the game for Lori and I.
You're very greedy,
Barbara.
No, it's not
greedy at all,
because I would develop
your business
in the same way
I developed Daisy Cakes,
and she went
from $25,000,
or $28,000
I think was the number,
and she's at close
to $4 million, okay?
So I've walked your road
before,
and I'd like Lori
to sell this on QVC.
Greiner:
Barbara, I appreciate your
extending an offer to me.
My problem with it
is I don't think
that this is
a QVC-type item.
-I'm going out...
-Okay. Thank you.
...but I think you have
a great offer on the table.
Barbara, Lori
won't dance with you.
Will you go on your own?
Let me mull on it.
Heather,
I also follow my gut.
Uh-huh.
And in my particular case,
my gut's gonna be
out to the door.
I love icing,
but I can't, I can't, I can't
because I'd be ginormous.
[ Sighs ]
I'm sorry, but I'm out.
All right.
Thank you, Mark.
Barbara?
-All right, Barbara.
You have an offer on the table
from Kevin already.
I would certainly give you
the same offer without Lori.
So, $75,000 for 30%,
Barbara?
Yes.
O'Leary:
I will say one thing.
Our unit volume is about
100 times that of Daisy Cake.
Your volume is not
100 times of Daisy Cakes.
The prob-- And the reason I --
At least, maybe more,
because we sell units
at $7.95.
-Dream on.
-Her cakes are $10,000 each.
She doesn't sell a lot.
[ Laughter ]
They're good, and she only has
to sell one!
The bottom --
I heard they're really good.
The reason
I want the extra equity
is I'm going to incentivize
my partners
to be partners with me
in this deal.
Well, Heather, their equity
is basically the same.
One's at 33%,
one's at 30%.
What does your gut say?
Who would you rather
be in business with,
Kevin or Barbara?
Heather,
we are both New Yorkers.
It makes a difference
to have face time
with who you're
in partnership with,
and I'm the best marketer
you'll ever lay eyes on.
I'll sell more of this stuff,
that's what'll happen.
-Believe me, his partners --
-You don't have with Daisy --
You can counter.
You can counter, Heather.
His partners are not gonna
put out a welcome mat
for you,
trust me on this.
O'Leary: What will happen is --
Heather,
what does your gut say?
Barbara, would you do 25%?
Yes, I would do 25%.
Okay. You have a deal.
You got it.
-Yeah!
-[ Chuckles ]
I'm pissed.
I, like, wanted you.
Thank you.
I love you. I wanted you.
More importantly,
screw you, Mr. Wonderful.
-Heather, great job.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations, Heather.
-Congratulations.
-I hope you buy some.
-Oh, trust me.
[ Chuckles ]
Thank you, guys.
Before today,
Dollop was a one-woman show,
and now it's a two-woman show,
and that feels incredible.
I really wanted Barbara,
and I feel like
there's so many
possibilities now,
and I feel like
we're just gonna kill it.
Narrator: In season six,
Dan Barnes and Wesley LaPorte
struck a deal with Lori Greiner
for their cellphone sanitizer,
PhoneSoap.
I want to take this unit,
put it on QVC,
and sell hundreds of thousands
of dollars in it, like that.
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
You touch your cellphone
all day long,
and when do you ever
clean your cellphone?
Yeah.
You just put this
into your phone to charge it.
It's UV light
and, in five minutes,
you've just
sanitized your phone.
LaPorte:
Lori said on "Shark Tank"
that she wanted to sell
hundreds of thousands
of dollars on QVC.
Actually,
we've sold millions.
Barnes: In the five months
before "Shark Tank,"
we did $537,000 in sales.
It's been just over a year,
and we've done $4.9 million.
Thanks for calling PhoneSoap.
This last year, we were just
trying to keep up with demand.
Now we're bursting
at the seams.
We've grown to 12 employees
and are busy just trying
to ship all the items
coming in.
We're actively looking
for new warehouse space
to keep up with demand
and expand our footprint.
When we first started,
we made a product
for consumer cellphones,
but as the market has evolved,
so have we.
We've introduced
PhoneSoap 2.0,
a universal version
for even larger phones.
And also PhoneSoap XL,
a version for tablets.
We know there's
a lot of opportunity
in healthcare and other
commercial applications,
and that's
our next big move.
Hey, Brooke, can I have a kiss?
[ Mwah ]
Growing up,
Wes and I always dreamt
of building
a business together,
and "Shark Tank" has literally
helped us fulfill our dreams.
It's changed our business
and our lives forever,
and we're so happy
to be able
to make the world
a healthier place.
All: PhoneSoap!
[ Cheering ]
Aloha.
My name is Mai Lieu,
and I live in Hawaii.
I was born in Vietnam
to Chinese parents.
When I was four,
we escaped the Vietnam War.
[ Voice breaking ] It was
very tough growing up.
We were poor.
We didn't know
how to speak English.
My parents worked two jobs.
It was very challenging.
Seeing my parents
work very hard inspired me
to create something for myself
and create success.
My parents are my role models.
They support me,
and they inspire me,
and I wouldn't have the life
that I have today without them.
Now it's my turn
to take care of them.
Now, after 20 years
in the beauty industry,
I've developed
an amazing line of products
inspired by my struggles
growing up.
It has the potential
to help so many families
save time and money,
and I can't wait
to share it with the Sharks.
What I need most
is a strategic partner.
A deal with the Sharks would
make all of my dreams come true.
Aloha!
[ Laughs ]
Sharks,
my name is Mai Lieu.
I'm from Honolulu, Hawaii,
and my company -- CreaProducts.
And I'm seeking $200,000
for 10% of my company.
Growing up, we couldn't afford
to go to the salon,
so my mom would always
cut my hair at home.
And my bangs would end up
way too short and uneven.
I'm sure many kids and parents
can relate.
And, ladies, what about those
pinot grigio bangs?
You know, after you've had
a couple glasses of wine,
and you decide
to cut your own hair?
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec:
Does that happen?
No, I don't think.
-I do it all the time.
-Well, there's no more excuses.
Introducing the CreaClip.
It's a hair-cutting guide
that allows you
to cut your hair at home,
and get a perfect cut --
great for cutting kids' hair,
bangs, and layers.
First, I'm gonna show you
how I cut my bangs.
You just gather all your bangs,
slide, and you just trim.
So I'm just trimming off
all the split ends.
This is gonna create
perfect bangs.
Done. Beautiful bangs.
-Oh!
So I have a larger size,
a large curved CreaClip.
This is gonna create layers,
and it's really easy.
I want to show you next...
Can you
demonstrate on Lori?
[ Laughs ]
I don't want to mess up
her beautiful hair.
You just
flip your head over...
clip the CreaClip...
[ Clicks ]
...slide...
Now this is the best part --
it has a built-in level.
That's how you know
it's perfectly balanced.
And we're going to trim!
[ Laughs ]
-No!
-Yes!
I'm gonna cut
all this hair!
Wow.
I surf a lot,
so I got a lot of split ends.
So, this is gonna cut --
get rid of all the split ends
and create beautiful layers.
Are you seeing
the level?
Yeah. Yeah.
You can see. You hold it up,
and you just cut.
Sharks, are you ready?
We're ready.
Done!
Look at this --
beautiful...
-Wow!
-Wow.
...beautiful layers.
And it creates a beautiful
layer shape in the back.
Now, Sharks, who wants to cut
a deal with CreaProducts?
I have some samples for you.
So...
Oh!
There's CreaNails?
Yes.
So this one...
That's the CreaClip.
I have the CreaNails for nails.
What is this?
This is for makeup, and I'll
definitely show you that.
All of this
is the same investment?
Yes.
It's all included.
Mai, how -- how many CreaClips
have you sold
in the last year,
dollar-wise?
Uh, in the last year?
$550,000.
O'Leary:
Just the CreaClip?
-Just the CreaClips.
-You're kidding.
O'Leary: Is that your
number-one product?
That's my
number-one product.
What about the other products
all together?
Well, the other products,
they're new.
Mai Lieu, do you demonstrate
it online?
Do you actually show people
how to do it?
You know how --
how people find me?
They see my videos
on YouTube.
Really?
So that's the driver.
So, I do instructional videos
on YouTube.
How many followers
do you have on YouTube?
-30,000.
-30,000?
I have 20 million views,
and just last month,
my video went viral
and 500,000 people
shared it,
and I sold out of product.
I sold 150,000 that week.
I don't think you mentioned
what you sell one for.
So, my CreaClip --
online I sell this for $30.
My CreaNails --
$24.95 plus shipping.
And my CreaLash -- $24.95.
So, what is --
what is that CreaLash,
and how do you use it?
Y-Y-You do this,
and you apply the shadow
so it doesn't fall
on your skin.
Also, it works great
for mascara.
You -- it lifts the lid,
apply the makeup,
and it actually bends
the lashes, creating more curl,
and you get the -- You don't get
mascara on your skin.
What's your background,
Mai?
Oh, I've been in the beauty
industry for 20 years.
As a hair cutter,
a hair stylist?
Yes. A hair stylist.
When I was four, my family
escaped the Vietnam War.
It was a hard time.
We didn't have any money.
[ Voice breaking ]
Um, my mom worked at McDonalds,
my dad worked night shift.
So I said, "when I grow up,
I'm gonna create success
no matter what.
I'm gonna take care
of my parents."
And, so, you know, now that
I've created all these products,
I-I want to continue to do that.
Your dream was to make money,
take care of your parents.
Have you been able
to make money
out of the $550,000
in sales?
Yes.
Yes, uh, my profit margin
is 66%, and I make $155,000.
Good for you.
Mai, um, I can really empathize
with your story
about escaping communism.
Yes.
You -- We have
the same background.
Same background.
So, here's
one thing I know.
People always
say this to me --
"Why do you have such
a chip on your shoulder?"
And I always say,
"Because of where I came from,
I had no choice."
I had to be successful
to justify
my parents' sacrifice for me.
Anything I do
for the rest of my life
will never be as hard
as what my dad did for me
escaping from that country --
ever.
My father never took
one day off.
He worked seven days a week,
from morning to night.
You are gonna succeed.
There is no doubt
in my mind.
Somebody with that heavy
a burden
and pressure
to be successful...
Robert.
...is gonna make it.
I want to be in business
with you.
I-I don't think
I'm the right partner
to help you sell nails.
I'm out.
Cuban: I'm gonna make things
a little simpler.
As much as I think
I could help you,
I'm probably not the best
partner for you.
Aww.
Good luck with these guys,
but I'm out.
Okay.
Clearly, for me,
hair products are not my focus.
Why?
[ Laughs ]
I'm out.
Okay.
O'Leary: Okay,
there's two Sharks left.
They both
happen to be women.
They don't cut their own hair,
but they have some.
[ Laughter ]
So, what do you girls
want to do?
In my -- I don't know
if Lori's interested
in this product, um...
Lori, QVC!
Well,
are you interested, Lori?
I think there's something
important
to people being able
to just --
not have to spend
a fortune
and be able to cut
their own bangs,
or do a straight blunt cut
across the back.
So, yes, Barb,
I-I would be interested
in partnering with Barb
on this one.
Okay, then,
guess what --
I'm gonna do it
a little differently.
I'm gonna give you
a full-price offer
for exactly what you want
from Lori.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Wow, Lori!
That's so generous!
Thank you!
That was Barb's offer.
You know, there's no better
motivation for an entrepreneur
than trying to prove something,
and that's what you've got.
But I have to say,
I think this product doesn't
have room for an investor.
I can't envision how I can make
money on this thing.
And not that
I don't like you,
but I'd like to make money
if I'm gonna put $200,000 in.
But as much as I love you,
I am out.
I know
that you are a go-getter.
that you are driven.
I am gonna offer you
the $200,000,
but I'm gonna offer at...
25%.
But this year, I'm gonna
be making $800,000 in sales,
this year alone.
I know, but I feel like
there's some engineering work
that needs to be done
on some things.
I feel that for the time
and the efforts
and what we're going
to need to do,
that would be the right
equity stake for me.
20%.
No.
I'm gonna stick at 25%.
25%.
[ Inhales sharply ]
Tough call.
I'll meet you halfway.
22.5%.
Lori, I came here
and I wanted you.
So it's a dream come true.
Thank you.
I'm gonna accept the offer.
All right. Good.
Yay!
Thank you so much!
Aww,
you're welcome.
Thank you,
thank you, yay!
Your hair looks good.
Oh, thank you.
It does, doesn't it?
Mm-hmm.
There's no mirror!
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God! Yay!
My parents supported me from
the beginning, and they're --
they're gonna be so proud
once I go back
and tell them the great news.
I liked her
as an entrepreneur.
I thought she really
had the guts.
-Oh, she's terrific.
-She was great.
-She's the real deal.
-She was good.
Narrator:
Next into the the Tank
are siblings
with a home-grown idea.
Hi, my name's Shelby Gogulski,
and I'm 15 years old.
And I'm Gordy Gogulski,
I'm 10, and I'm her minion!
We're from Jacksonville,
Florida,
and our company
is Yourself Expression.
We're seeking $50,000
in exchange for
20% of our company.
Yourself Expression
is an interchangeable
accessories company
that allows
just one piece of jewelry
to be over 1,000
different designs!
After wanting
a pair of expensive boots
just 'cause of the cute bow
on the back,
my mom told me, "No way."
So I decided to create my own
bows to match what I wore.
This crafty project
got us searching
for anything we can create,
wear, and change.
♪ Create, wear,
and change ♪
[ Laughter ]
Yourself Expression
has five unique
interchangeable collections
that are designed
for women, men, kids,
and even the family pet.
We are considered a fun,
affordable addiction,
and our customers can't stop
adding to their collections.
From holidays to hobbies,
one perfect base...
can be endless designs.
We are asking for you all
to be a part
of our growing company
as we move into the souvenir,
character,
and sports-team industry
while growing our current
products for everyday wear.
Both: So, who's ready
to snap to it, and let's do it!
Thank you so much.
Gordy will now pass out
your gifts.
Cool. Good job, guys.
All the jewelry you're wearing
is yours, right?
-Yes.
-Nice.
All of it? The belt?
Yes, the belt, the flip flops,
the hair tie.
-Thank you, Gordy.
-Earrings, necklace...
-Yes.
So, Shelby, each piece
comes with a unique,
circular
little round thing?
Yes, uh, each piece comes
with just the snap base...
Okay.
...and then the Poppers
come separate.
So, I-I buy it...
You buy it blank, and then you
pop your design in.
...I buy it like this...
Yeah, you buy your blank,
and then you pop the design in.
...and then I buy
these designs?
Shelby: Yes.
We sell them individually.
We have a website.
We have a shop. We have --
Who designs them,
Shelby?
Um, I design them and we have
four manufacturers
that also help us design.
And do you have any retail
d-distribution?
Can I buy it in
a store anywhere?
Um, yes, we are in 90 retail
locations right now.
We're in a few boutiques,
hospitals, gift shops,
and in a few Hallmarks.
So what are your sales
gonna be this year?
$365,000.
So, hang on a sec.
You're 15 and you're 10,
and you're selling a grand a day
in your business?
-Yes.
-Sometimes more.
So, who owns the company?
Um, my entire family
owns a portion.
I own 35%.
Gordy owns 20%.
-Gordy, come on!
-My mom owns 25%.
What happened to you,
Gordy?
Your sister screwed you?
-[ Laughs ]
Can you tell us
how you started it and when?
I actually started it --
I actually started it, um,
a little over a year ago.
I was trying
to find a way
to help my parents
pay for my high-school tuition,
and I was making this -- these
interchangeable boot clips.
And I was just thinking,
"This isn't gonna
be a company,
I'm just gonna sell
to friends and family."
But then, I brought Gordy in,
we started designing,
and then in August
of last year,
we had our website created,
and from then till now,
we've done $250,000
in sales.
-What's your cost...
-Yes.
...and how much money
do you make on it?
Our Poppers cost us
between 30 cents and $1.
We resell them for $4.
And our bases cost us
between a $1.20 and $4,
and we resell those
between $10 and $14.
Wow.
You're making great margins.
Gordy, you're the finance guy,
right?
'Cause you answered
the finance question.
All right, so, your sales
are at $300,000
last year or this year?
$250,000 this year.
We're gonna do $365,000
in this year.
I love how you go
into the deep finance voice
when you say that.
-[ Chuckles ]
How much profit will you make
at the end of the day?
Out of $250,000 we've --
net sales have been $80,000.
All right.
So you're doing great.
Why do you need a Shark?
What's a Shark
gonna do for you?
Well, we need your, like,
business expertise,
and your connections
to theme parks, cruise lines,
boutiques,
and souvenir shops.
Our main goal is to get
into the souvenir industry.
We want character and sports
licensing.
That's why we're here,
because we want to grow
our men's and kids' collection,
and we can see this definitely
in the souvenir industry.
That's pretty astute,
you know, for your age.
You not only have started a
business, been very successful,
but now you actually
even know a path
that you think's going
to propel you farther.
Corcoran:
I want to tell you a story.
I invested with Mark
in a business
called Villy's Custom Bikes.
Oh, don't go there.
"Don't go there," he said.
[ Chuckles ]
Beautiful bike,
beautiful entrepreneur,
but he had
a similar situation to you.
He had, probably,
300 different bells
you could customize
for your bike --
300 different tire wheels,
300 different seat colors,
and on and on it went.
And this is, I think,
a problem you're going to have
with your business here.
My word of advice would be --
you really have to figure out
what's selling
and concentrate on that.
Even though
it's not as much fun
to make a viable business
out of this, for me,
it's just not a business
I see making a lot of money,
and so I'm out. I'm sorry.
So, Shelby, this business
is defined by inventory.
This is a nightmare
in inventory management.
The bigger you get, the more
the challenge is gonna be.
It's amazing
what you've done,
but when I put money to work,
I'm deadly serious about it.
I'm out.
Gordy, I have to commend you
on the tie, first of all.
Corcoran: [ Laughs ]
You look fantastic,
well dressed a 10.
With your own blood, sweat,
and tears,
you created a business
that you're gonna, on track,
make a $100,000 a year.
It's -- It -- I mean,
it's just unbelievable
at your age, Shelby's age.
Are you okay, Shelby?
[ Voice breaking ]
I don't know why I'm crying.
Oh, don't cry.
Oh.
You've worked so hard.
[ Sniffles ]
You're doing so amazing.
You're doing great.
You okay?
Want some water?
I don't know why
I'm crying.
Kevin, can you leave?
You're making the children cry.
-Yeah!
-[ Laughs ]
I don't know why I'm crying.
I'm just crying.
You know,
the funny thing about retail,
one of the things they measure,
is sales per square foot.
So if you can sell
a lot of stuff
with the smallest amount
of footprint,
that's what big retailers
get really excited about.
This, combined with this,
could be a good business,
like, a really good business
that you could take wide.
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah, Exactly.
-Right?
Look, I love you guys.
You -- You --
You make me feel bad
that I haven't done enough
with my life, because you're --
you're so far ahead.
[ Laughter ]
But i-it's not for me.
Great job,
but I'm not your Shark.
I'm out.
This is a great company,
but this isn't the best
that you're
gonna be able to do.
You'll reach a point where
you say, "You know what?
This was
a great starter kit."
Well, I think
this is gonna be my future,
because I want
to be the next Pandora, okay?
I mean, you go to Disney,
you've seen Pandora,
and everybody's
surrounded by it,
'cause there's
all these Disney charms.
And I want to go into Disney
and see Yourself Expression
and all the Poppers
with the characters,
and see people swarming.
I mean, people are addicted
this -- to this stuff.
They love it!
Look, I like it.
I-I think the product's great.
But I truly believe
you'll find bigger
and better things to do.
And Gordy will take over,
he'll find bigger and better
things to do.
I just don't want you to have
the pressure of saying --
okay, now that you've taken
money --
because I-I think
people fail to realize
your obligations change,
you know?
It's not just about
growing the business,
it's also about
supporting the investor,
dealing with the investors.
I'm out.
You know,
I was listening to you,
and you remind me of a saying
I have that I love,
which is, "It isn't
'Who's going to let me?'
It's 'Who's
going to stop me?'"
You have
that drive in you.
Right now,
you're so successful that,
actually, as a Shark,
I might complicate things
for you.
I wish you the best of luck.
I'm out.
Thank you. [ Sniffles ]
Gordy, before you go,
ask your sister for more equity.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations, guys.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
It's beautiful jewelry.
Shelby:
I was disappointed 'cause
they didn't really get it,
the sports
and the characters
and the -- the big process
we could have for this,
but I realize I got a lot
of great advice from them
in that -- you're gonna see me
in a few years, I guess.
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is a toy that combines
the fun of skating and surfing.
Hi.
I'm Randy Putland.
My name's
Bernie Miller.
I'm Reuben Guymer.
We're all from San Diego,
and we are the Spooner guys.
We're seeking $400,000
for 16% of our company.
Sharks, meet the Spooner.
It is the ultimate
board trainer
for simulating surf,
skate, and snowboard moves
on any surface.
You can ride it,
slide it, flip it, spin it.
Kids love them.
They just jump on it
and immediately start developing
their balance and coordination
while making up their own tricks
and having fun at it.
Speaking of tricks, we have
a real treat for you Sharks.
We do.
He's nationally
and internationally known
as the hardest-working man
on the Spooner,
Master Spooner, Mr. Spooner,
the Star of the Spooner,
Reuben Guymer!
Get him, Reub!
Nice, nice!
There it is!
[ Laughs ]
Nice!
Watch out! Watch out!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my -- oh, my God!
Hold on, hold on,
hold on!
[ Laughter ]
Get him some water.
We'll be all right.
What?
Wait a minute.
I'm not done, man!
I got to ride the Yardboard!
Miller:
Hey, helmet!
The Yardboard.
Guymer:
So this is a Yardboard.
It's a all-terrain
downhill slider.
The snow's the best,
but I like to ride these ramps,
grass, dirt -- dirt, snow.
Here we go!
Putland: Get it!
Yeah! Nice!
Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Cool.
-Thank you.
Sharks, with our boards,
kids as young as three years old
can start dreaming of becoming
a true boarder some day,
starting
right in their own bedroom.
And, Sharks, you know,
when we're out in the surf,
we usually like to stay away
from you guys,
but today we're willing
to make an exception,
so who wants to jump on board
the Spooner team?
We've got some boards
for these guys.
-Cool, thank you.
-Robert.
-Lori.
-Thank you.
-Mr. Wonderful.
-Thank you, thank you.
So it's simulating, like,
riding a wave
or -- or going down a ski slope?
Exactly. Yeah.
O'Leary: Okay.
Tell us about the business.
Yes, It's a funny story.
I have a small surf shop.
I bought a dog igloo,
plastic dog igloo.
So I picked up my saw,
and I started
cutting this dog igloo,
and I said, "Man,
there's a skateboard deck."
So I make six of them,
just hand did them,
and I put wheels on them,
but they hit the ground,
they didn't work.
So they were just
laying like this
the whole time
in the back of the surf shop.
But kids just started
getting on them
and playing
and spinning and jumping.
Okay.
So then what happens?
You start realizing
kids want them?
Well --
Well, we went --
Cuban: Surf --
you have a surf shop, right?
So you have a place
to sell them.
We did $52,000.
We sold 1,100 boards
in 6 weeks.
Was that Christmas season?
Yes.
It was the Christmas --
yeah. Absolutely.
O'Leary: Were you demonstrating
the boards?
How do people know
what to do with them
when they just look at them?
We had, like 50 boards
out all around the kiosk.
-Wow.
-And you were demonstrating it?
We demoed, yeah.
What was the cost
for one board?
It was $45 for the small one
and $55 for the large one.
This is the Pro model
and you're on the Freestyle.
It's just
a little bit smaller --
This is $45?
-This is the small?
-Yes, sir. Yes.
Corcoran:
And what does it cost you
to make the $45 one
and the $55 one?
It's about $12
and $12.50.
O'Leary:
Those are good margins.
Yeah. I'd say.
At what volume are you
running those at today?
Last year,
we did $1.73 million
and this year we're on line
to do about $1.8 million.
Whoa.
And how are you selling
most of these, online?
Guymer:
65% of our business
is specialty retail stores,
toy stores.
There's about 1,200
really good ones that we're in.
That's our bread and butter,
'cause little kids
get on this board,
and as soon as they're on it,
they just immediately engage.
Randall, how did you go
to $1.7 million?
We really opened up
at the New York Toy Fair.
We got a huge booth.
2,000 --
This display is great.
So, is -- was that
your display at the toy show?
-Yes.
-We had a lot bigger one.
We had a big one.
We have a 30-foot one.
We started out
because we couldn't afford
to go to,
uh, the toy fair,
'cause it's
a lot of money to go.
We started out in the
physical education programs
all across the U.S.
We would sell 130 boards
at a normal school show,
and that would be enough
to pay the rent.
Oh, we're in over 15,000
elementary P.E. programs.
Where do you make these?
We make them
in San Diego.
We're made in America,
100%.
Do you pay yourselves
something?
We have a $60,000
a year salary for each of us.
From $1.8 million,
including your salaries,
what will the business
make as a profit?
We made about $400,000.
Oh, you guys
are making great money.
Good for you, guys.
Congrats.
Yeah.
There's no debt
on the business?
Putland: There's no debt.
There's no
other shareholders?
No. Just the three of us.
Randall, what's the problem?
[ Laughter ]
-What do you need the money for?
-Then what do you need us for?
What's missing?
Here's the --
You guys are missing!
We want you guys
to get on board!
But how would you use
the $400,000?
Doesn't sound like
you need it.
Well, you know, we've -- we've
stayed in our little niche,
which is
the specialty toy market.
We haven't really
branched out.
The New York Toy Fair,
where you went,
is not a specialty show.
Every major retailer
goes there.
Herjavec: There must have been
a big box retailer
that tried
to bring you in.
I-It was Toys"R"Us.
All: And what happened?
The thing is that we have
some fear going to the big box.
Why?
Because it takes
a lot of money to put that out.
You didn't do it
because you were concerned
to be
overextending yourself.
Exactly.
How do you guys
manage the business?
What do each of you do?
We're kind of unique
because we wear a lot of hats.
We manufacture
right in our own warehouse,
and we distribute
in our own warehouse, also.
Bernie runs
all the manufacturing.
Reuben is the sales
and marketing director.
I run the numbers.
I'm the CFO.
I love the whole story.
I love your distribution.
The schools -- You have
a fantastic business.
You make money.
You're doing
what you love to do,
and you get to work with people
that are fun and you love.
That's the American dream.
But here's the problem --
you bring an investor in,
any of us,
it just becomes
a different ballgame.
When you bring in
outside money,
there's a level
of discipline,
because it's not yours
anymore.
And is that something
that you want to do?
Cuban: Basically, it means
changing your lifestyle.
I-I'll give you
the perfect example.
There's a company that came on
here, "SURFSET Fitness."
We went out,
and sales started going like
this, this, this,
this, this, this, this.
But the amount of effort,
the amount of time
that they had to put in
started going up
even faster.
And it got to the point --
Mike and Sarah
got to the point,
were like,
"We don't have
our lives anymore.
We're not who we were."
They paid us back all of
our money, plus a return.
We still keep our equity.
Now they do it
at their own leisurely pace.
They weren't ready
to make that step.
I don't think you guys are ready
to make that lifestyle change.
While you're thinking about
all the spooky stuff
that Mark's talking about,
I'm gonna put an offer
on the table.
Wow.
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
and Barbara has an offer coming
for Reuben, Randy, and Bernie's
recreational board, Spooner.
Cuban:
I don't think you guys are ready
to make that lifestyle change.
While you're thinking about
all the spooky stuff
that Mark's talking about,
I'm gonna put an offer
on the table.
Wow.
I'm gonna give you
half the money --
$200,000 for 8%,
but you have to get the other
Shark in for the balance.
All right?
Okay.
We --
That sounds great, Barbara.
Corcoran: But let me tell you
why I think you are ready.
When you declined to go ahead
with a big box store,
you did it for
the right business reasons.
That was
the right move.
You didn't have the cash
to put out or to cover it.
I mean, of course
you made a good judgment.
You've built your business
little by little.
There's my half offer...
Wow.
...but you have to get
the other half.
We love that, Barbara.
Thank you so much.
O'Leary:
All right, guys, look,
I'm interested
in partnering with her,
but I don't get up for 8%.
I'm not interested.
Except for him.
Any other Shark
other than he.
All right, then I'll take
the whole deal myself.
I'd structure the deal
a little differently.
I don't think
you should sell your equity,
and I'll tell you why.
You guys have had a relationship
for many years together.
It's like a family.
You bring a shareholder,
that's a whole
different ball game.
No, not with
the right shareholder.
I don't need your opinion,
Barbara.
It doesn't matter to me.
I'm giving it anyway.
What I'm gonna tell you
is this --
Barbara.
What you need is capital
to fund this growth.
You need a banker
that basically believes
you can pay him back.
So here's
what I would do --
I would give you the $400,000
in tranches,
$100,000 at a time.
I'm gonna ask you
to pay me back at $2 a board.
I want to at least
get a return on my money,
as any banker would.
So, for example,
I give you the $400,000,
I want $800,000 back
at $2 a board.
If somebody buys the company,
I'd like 3% as an option,
but I don't have
any voting rights at all.
In other words,
you guys run the business.
Corcoran:
How complicated.
Would you like to call
your accountant on this?
Pretty simple, actually.
It's very simple.
It's actually a way
for you to keep your business
because what works
for you guys
is the culture
you've built and the trust
you have in each other
over all that time.
You don't need
a shareholder.
You don't want
Herjavec: Well, the advantage
of that deal, actually,
is he's not a shareholder.
But he's got to get paid.
He's the Grim Reaper.
O'Leary: Any banker
has to get paid back.
You can call a banker
anything you'd like.
They got to get a return.
Do you feel like
that's quite a high interest?
[ Laughter ]
Well, it's gonna take me almost
five years to get it back.
Greiner: But you were saying
you're not really looking
for the cash necessarily.
-We're looking for --
-You need a strategic partner.
Yes.
Listen, guys, I've talked Mark
into the deal.
He'll take the other half
of the deal...
Really? Nice!
...which is the 8%
at the same valuation, $200,000.
And here's why I said yes,
because Tower Paddle Boards --
stand-up pa--
they're in San Diego.
You guys
can help each other,
but you got to say
"yes" or "no" right now.
Greiner: Well, so now
they're forcing your hands
so that you don't listen
to what the other Sharks say.
No, we're not.
It's just the perfect deal.
You can say "no," but it's just
up to you to say -- Yeah.
O'Leary:
You don't have to do any--
You can listen
to the other offers.
It's not -- You don't
have to do that.
You know, there could be
a better offer
waiting in the wings,
so...
I think Mark's gonna
give you the 10-second clock.
Here's the way I look at it --
there's no secrets anymore.
You all know what we do.
You all watch the show.
You all do your homework.
And if you say "no" to us,
we'll survive.
If you want to
take your chances with them --
But we don't want to do
all the back-and-forth.
Reuben, there's an offer
coming from Lori.
I would like
to give you an offer.
Wait.
Give them a moment.
I would --
If they listen
to your offer --
Barbara, why
do you keep talking?
Greiner:
I will give you --
Give them a moment of silence.
I'm going to give you
an offer --
Mark and Barbara
offered them
exactly what
they were looking for.
Exactly.
And I'm not -- I'm not saying
we're gonna stay in, guys.
Guys, I'm not saying
we're gonna stay in.
-Let's do it.
-Let's do it! Let's do it!
I'm gonna give you
an offer --
We thought it over,
and "Yes!"
Smart judgment.
Yeah, we're coming up.
-Yeah!
-Yeah.
Thank you so much,
you guys.
You didn't hear it.
Oh, yeah!
[ All talking ]
You know we, really appreciate
all your feedback.
You guys are awesome.
-Thank you, guys.
Cuban:
Appreciate it, guys.
[ Laughs ]
-That was so awesome!
-I can't even believe it.
I can't believe
how awesome that was.
So, Barbara, you have a new
theory in the Shark Tank now.
What's that?
"We're gonna give people exactly
what they're looking for."
Hey, they were worth it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]